bonjour bonjour maïté devant nous alors
moi je m'amuse layan ses ballets oui
c'est beau oui elles sont les esprits
donc c'est des escargots de bordeaux le
petit gris de bordeaux ne faut pas
confondre avec l'escargot de bourgogne
pas du tout beaucoup plus gros et qu'on
ne traite pas de la même manière
exactement c'est préférer sa naturelle
ils ont plus de saveur alors là ils ont
l'air de 100 brasse mais ils se montrent
de surface qui font rien qu'à ce qu'ils
ont dans la salle à défendre alors ils
ont tout ce qu'il faut pour être heureux
à voir les aviez traité déjà il me
semble bien entendu à la gasconne
c'était avec un avec un beau gâchis de
jambon et aujourd'hui vous allez les
faire que vous eh bien on va faire un
fricassée d'escargots à la purée d'ortie
des sorties oui mais quand j'ai entendu
dire autrefois dans les campagnes qu'on
soignait les rhumatismes en se frottant
avec désolé j'ai jamais entendu
tellement et bien écoutez moi non plus
vous non plus non non plus vous avez
essayé j'ai essayé et j'ai goûté et jose
assure c'est délicieux c'est meilleur
que les avis que les pillards cela c'est
doux c'est délicieux il faudra goûter
vous allez voir en slip away
il faudrait il faut des grands ou alors
j'imagine qu'il faudra pas que des
sorties bien entendu qu'est ce qu'il
faut dire que non alors une faut d'abord
du vinaigre c'est que je n'ai grain
d'estragon ruisseau dans la chance de
l'avoir
il nous faut de l'armagnac il nous faut
désormais bien entendu il nous faut des
coques du poivron des champignons on
peut choisir de champillon kong il
analyse les roms auraient pu mettre
aussi bien des serres exactement ce
qu'on veut il nous faut des tomates du
père s'il le faut de l'échalote du
citron et deux états
et notre corps de ballet exactement la
première des opérations c'est dommage de
les distraire ils ont l'air si heureux
bien ça il faudra bien qu est ce qu on
va et vient écouter on va les nettoyer
ans va les tuer
et bien voilà ouali qui est nettoyé
s'était alors eva les laver exactement
qu'est-ce qu'il faut du sel du gros sel
beaucoup oui la nef est pas mal et on
sera prêt du vinaigre pareil parce que
rien deviner
avant me litres moi j'ai pas mal et on
va mettre les escargots valeur mes
petits chéris hop on y va avec avait
déjà des candidats aussi civilisés sur
le bord de la bassine en ramasser des
escargots
on va pas les mettre tous dans l'esprit
closer et voyez c'est mona grand-mère
autrefois me devais faire des escargots
pour moi trois jours pour les nettoyer
parce que ça va eh bien on va lui faire
est grande que changer long et rechange
et l'eau voilà on va mettre des orties
ans les marges
on s'en sert pour tous et la barbe va
rester au milieu des autres
vous voulez dire que avec des orties et
de l'eau et du sel et du binaire il
suffit de les laver une croisade le mans
alors qu'autrefois il bavait par
endroits jours et on n'aura plus qu'à
les jeunes c'est après vous allez voir
ça ils vont pas laisser 50 fois sa
traditionnelle d'espagne montrez-nous
ces heurts qui ont peut voir si ça
commence sa collection aussi tous les
ans des nauves regarder comment aider
les débutants
voilà la différence un voleur n'a pas
beaucoup et qui avait le publia et en
quelques minutes c'est très exactement
la voilà et maintenant vas reims et
c'est bon ces bourgeois et ensuite on va
les mettre à cuire
vous m'avez dit il faut que nous
préparions à court bouillon on va
préparer le court bouillon
qu'est ce qu'il faut eh bien il faut il
ne compte avec de l'eau bien entendu
fruits lincetto on va mettre le sel des
grosses faire du gros sel
voilà vue on va y mettre du poivre ne
regrettez pas là les dires une bonne
cuillère à généreux on va y mettre car
donnant la chance d'avoir un bon
bien le mais ça ne gâche rien du tout et
on y met le poireau le poireau là on met
une carotte et on met l'oignon piqué
dans tout l'iran oui mais enfin on va
remettre un peu petit peu plus comme ça
oui mais voilà on met deux live oui on
met un piment fort
oui ça va être bien relevé une tranche
de jambon lutter vous allez me demander
du laurier oui un petit prince il rit
tout petit oublier un peu de persil
rêvons anna et pour fini les escargots
n'était pas un peu de partout
umberto merci j'ai joué que vous aviez
dit c'est micheline ce n'est pas avec ça
ça l'arrangé énormément mais je doute
que ça va faire un bon usage et là
dedans et les escargots que je vais
prendre comme ceux ci il faudra
longtemps pour les clips au minimum deux
heures de temps ouhlala oui ces mots ne
sont pas une heure ont fait ça quand
même ça voilà
bon et bien pâles en ce que m'avait dit
qu'il faudrait s'occuper des sorties ou
des sorties tout de suite cette purée
comme on l'a fait tôt c'est très facile
on prend nos tout leur dit non
ah non là ce serait alors ce serait un
bénéfice terrible emprunt classique
d'ortiz est un jeu de patience et voilà
qui pousse bien existante au bout la
route au bout voilà c'est cette partie
là là je pense je prends l'alliance les
mais là on avait alors là j'ai mis une
casserole d'eau à bouillir voilà vous
continuer pendant que je fais ça je vais
du sel dans la casserole
je prends mes pointes d'ortie comme ceci
quant à dire que j'y croyais pas moi
seul est la soeur de ses formes et la
voilà là et vous les mettez en tout
temps dans l'eau bouillonne on aidera
les oies il s'agit quand les blancs qui
seulement celle où est un bouillon c'est
à dire que tu as le bouillon voilà après
on va la sortir là
dié j'aurais juste que vous me disiez
s'est désolé d'ortie de votre jardin ou
ses déprimes sous la barre 2d vous les
trouvez au noir dans laquelle vous
retrouver au bord de la route au bord
des champs au bord des barradels partout
surtout y en a ça fonce au monde et se
repérer sa à la saison il y en a pas
tout tracé des petits trucs de printemps
ce voile à la bbc beaurains alors on va
le sortir
oui mais c'est si simple mais c'est si
simple
et c'est si bon là on n'y pense pas
parce que ça brûle bien les orties alors
on a l'impression que les allemands
savent a brûlé l'intérieur de gaza qui
fait entre l'homme et des grands prix
facturé plus de sortir les cas
maintenant voilà ça y est et après et
après et après da matériels sont bien
dégoûté je vais me les mettre sur la
planche sur ma planche mans là là je
vais m comme ça je vais les hacher a
comme une persillade
parce que si on n'est pas à l'abri non
non pas très frappant là c'est bon on va
aller [ __ ] valorisables avec m dans un
verbe
d'où là c'est bon elles sont réduites à
sec très bien ce à dire que le vin est
complètement évaporé quoi maintenant on
va mettre la crème fraîche nuit une
cuillerée sa fifille lèvres très bien le
beurre je vous donne du beurre un petit
peu un petit noir et ensuite je suis sûr
que vous allez me demander les ordres
est sorti je voulais passer
oui et on va mélanger le tout
les voilà très bien voilà mais la
recette n'est pas fini encore rien du
tout maintenant est ce qu'on va faire on
va mettre au chaud on va le mettre au
chaud la salle andré dufour avec 1,8
réduit mais plus comme si peu de poivre
parce qu'on a tous à vélo oui mais voilà
on va le tenir sa motion je le mets en
cours et vous qu'est-ce que vous allez
en faire et bien on va s'occuper des
girolles et des copains on s'en occupe
comment est bon et prend les met dans la
poêle et bière chaude ça souffle tout
notre événement a très bien souvent dans
l'euro alors on va rajouter nous vivons
oui mais m la moitié des vols
on va y mettre les tomates non formaté
comme ce joli la serbie oui quelques
feuilles de version grossière va couper
voilà donc le foyer comme ça très bien
et on se doit pas à mouiller comme un
griot chose alors on va les mettre un
petit peu d'armagnac envahi m voilà
c'est peu
là
et en 2002 flambée un petit peu flammes
et sa femme tout seul il sera pas plus
mauvaise et c'est tout il ya encore sept
le nombre peuvent être viables à wil et
là je crois sud oui mais voilà la
flandre et puis c'est tout mais on ne se
réduire et bien puisqu'il faut que ça
réduit un certain temps on pourrait
peut-être regarder ce qui se passe avec
les escargots qui ont cuit deux heures
il se défend facilement de la coquille
et parce que ce qui se défend bien et
s'ils sont bien loin oui oui mais quoi
ce que vous voulez voir un corps dedans
avec celle que vous aide
c'est tout de suite à gesté la voilà et
maintenant on va les rajouter un autre
concorde dans le ragot daumas il est
après celui des emplois il est réduit
regarder très bien alors on va mettre
tous à londres voilà aurait bien merci
c'est parfait
il ne reste plus qu'à ajouter la purée
d'olives oui mais on va mettre nos
escargots aussi dans le plat attendez je
vous apporte la paix pour mélanger c'est
la fricassée d'escargots mon avis
d'escargots le gascon depuis escargots
gascon avec les doigts ils entreprirent
de tomates avec du vin blanc est une
bonne chose et voilà la purée de nature
et d'orties qu'on mélange et on mélange
tout et enfin être un peu des pieds de
tomates
ça c'est pour faire joli et encore une
appétissant voilà et de flins est
terminée et bien pour ceux qui aiment
les escargots que tout le monde ne les
aime pas moi j'ai goûté je peux vous
dire que c'est très très bon parce que
le paiement le 20 toutes les bonnes
choses cas de deux ans je ne suis pas si
c'est encore meilleur que les escargots
qu'on avait fait avant à la garonne avec
achi c'est très fin alors amateurs
d'escargots à vous d'essayer et à
bientôt
[Musique]